hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
the Samsung Galaxy s4 will easily be one
of the most popular phones of 2013 no
doubt and when Samsung builds up that
much hype for any phone like they do
with the s4 especially when the
predecessor the s3 is so popular we kind
of expect the s4 to be a really good
phone and a lot of people see the Galaxy
s4 as an evolutionary update to the
galaxy s3 and understandably so because
of the naming but after my time with it
I'm seeing it a bit differently I'm
seeing the galaxy s4 as more of a
downsized reconstructed note to hear me
out
so the galaxy s4 is more square than the
galaxy s3 first of all and although it
has very similar dimensions Samsung will
tell you that it's slightly thinner and
slightly lighter so that's true but you
won't really notice these differences if
you're familiar with the galaxy s3 you
also feel right at home with the button
layout and the port layout because
they're the same on the galaxy s4 and
they're also the same as they are on the
galaxy note 2 but overall the phone just
looks and feels just different different
in the way the Galaxy Note 2 feels
different from the s3 mostly because
this design again it's more square and
then you check out the insides you
already know that you can take off the
back the thin flexible plastic back of
the galaxy s4 to reveal the internals
and that will reveal a removable 2600
milliamp hour battery and a micro SD
card slot and the speaker micro SIM card
etc now compare this to the galaxy s3 on
the left and the galaxy note 2 on the
right and there is even more reason to
consider the s4 a restructured note to
the speaker is now down in the bottom at
the same place the battery is also now
lower in the chassis and the microSD
card and micro SIM card slots are now
above the battery instead of below all
these like the note 2 not the s3 also on
the galaxy s3 the edges were so tapered
that you had no real edge of the phone
to grip and that was a bit of a problem
for me but with the new s4 design you
actually have that metallic band around
the phone that creates an edge to grip
before the tapering starts it's a small
touch and it's something a lot of
reviewers look past as a cheap attempt
to look more premium but it actually
really changes the feel of the galaxy s4
in the hand
you hold it so on the hardware side of
things consider this guy a compacted
Galaxy Note 2 that's just the way it
feels in the hand and the way it's built
on the software side of things though
this is familiar Samsung territory so
here on the galaxy s4 we have an updated
TouchWiz on top of Android 4.2 jelly
bean this time so first of all since
it's Android 4.2 now you get a bunch of
new google features like for example the
quick settings in the notification bar
that Samsung so generously colorized and
added to they're accessible with a two
finger swipe down from the top of the
notification bar and you can basically
customize them to let you one tap toggle
any feature on the phone which is
actually kind of nice it's convenient
and you also get Android 4.2 S lock
screen widgets and the first one I
install it as dashclock of course
because it's beautiful but yeah plenty
of apps are supported you can swipe to
the right to open the camera or swipe to
add more lock screen widgets there a
welcome addition that the Galaxy s3 and
note 2 don't have yet and then there's
the rest of TouchWiz so Samsung stuffed
this phone to the gills with software
features inside of TouchWiz a lot of
them will make for great commercials and
gimmicky tricks and neat demos so this
one is very demo able which is very good
for Samsung but in the end a lot of
these features probably won't be used by
the average user so for example air view
is new it lets you hover your finger
over an album in the gallery to get a
preview of the photos inside it's useful
it works but it's an extra gesture you
have to learn and people are used to
just tapping in an opening gallery
anyway so I don't know if people will
use that there's also things like smart
scroll and smart stay and smart pause
and all this smart stuff that's supposed
to basically read your eyes using a
front-facing camera and take action or
adjust itself accordingly they all work
most of the time but if you have them on
by accident or you don't want them to be
on you may find your phone scrolling up
and down or pausing videos or changing
orientation by itself when you didn't
want or need it to do that so I ended up
turning these features off after a while
they got annoying and I just didn't need
them and I did an explanation video of
all these things so I'll leave a link
right below the like button on this
video if you want an explanation of all
the galaxy s4 software features but
basically overall TouchWiz has a
lot of new added features that are like
I said great for demos it's great for
showing off to your friends or something
like that but eventually I turn them off
because they just weren't doing it for
me I don't really need them overall
though TouchWiz is still very colorful
as we've seen on other devices and very
very contrast II just like on the galaxy
s3 and the note 2 and touch which is
very contrasting because it's also on
that M OLED display and speaking of that
display this is no ordinary AMOLED
display the galaxy s4 is rocking a 1920
by 1080 Super AMOLED plus display so
that gives it a pixel density of 441
pixels per inch and it does have a
pentile sub pixel matrix but nobody can
tell this display has far more pixels in
that 5 inch space than any naked eye can
decipher and that means razor sharp text
images video everything I love it
it's what we've been waiting for it
which what we knew was coming in the
upgrade to the s4 and it is the number
one reason to upgrade to this phone from
something like the galaxy s3 now because
it's an AMOLED display it also has a few
advantages over other 1080p phones for
example in deeper blacks higher contrast
and lower power consumption but all of
that comes with the trade-off that this
display is no brighter than the galaxy
s3 so it kind of struggles in daylight
when compared to something like the HTC
One but that's of course another video
now it's pushing these pixels with the
Snapdragon 600 processor in the United
States which if you don't know is an
absolute tank of a processor just a
performance monster benchmark killer and
all-around great chip so it's going to
score really high on pretty much any
benchmark that you put it through and
it's also going to get you great power
consumption as well so I was able to get
all-day battery life again about the
same battery life as the galaxy s3 with
the stock battery I was using the galaxy
s3 on Verizon which was an LTE network
and I was using the galaxy s4 on AT&T
which is now te network and I was
getting about the same battery life so
despite the more powerful processor and
the bigger sharper display you're going
to get about the same battery which is
pretty good for me all day now you can't
talk about that galaxy s4 without a
little bit about that camera and I gotta
say it is an
awesome one I'd say the best camera on
any smartphone I've ever used to date
and that's including the latest iPhone 5
the Galaxy Note 2 the galaxy s3 the HTC
One the Lumia 920 this tops them all for
me this is just an awesome all-around
solid performing 13 megapixel camera for
pretty much all types of situations the
camera app of course is updated to the
new version of TouchWiz so it looks a
lot like the interface on the samsung
galaxy camera now and again it's filled
with all these tons of gimmicky TouchWiz
features that most people will never
even know they have in their pocket but
a few of them were actually kind of cool
so people like to get creative with
their cameras you know so for example I
fell in love with the animated photo
feature that lets you take a few seconds
of video clip and then basically animate
just a part of it to form a jiff and
there are so many unique ways to use is
it's not even funny I was walking around
New York City all the time just taking
these and the only real problem is
sharing them because pretty much only
Google+ supports gifs that big but it
was very cool to use that feature and I
also take HDR's a lot so it was good to
see HDR make another appearance in this
new version no photo spheres
unfortunately kind of sucks since we're
on android 4.2 and everything but yeah I
guess they can get away with omitting
that I'll include a full resolution
panorama I took in New York in the
description below so you can see the
real quality because YouTube won't
really let me show you just how
good-looking the photos this thing takes
are but trust me when I say they are
beautifully sharp and detailed with all
those pixels and definitely good with
the color department too it's a solid
performer in low-light as well it's no
Lumia 920 it's no HTC One and low-light
but it definitely produces acceptable
photos and pretty much any lighting
situation which lets me give it the
crown of the best all-around camera in a
smartphone so at the end of the day
there are a lot of things to like about
the sonne from the 1080p display to the
battery life to the note 2 like squarish
design to the things like you know the
little TouchWiz improvements on top of
Android 4.2 yet then again there are
plenty of things not to like for example
the Settings app which took a huge step
down and currently sucks with this lame
tabbed interface that you can't even
swipe through to get but it's really all
about your values on when it comes to
judging things like that and
the huge question at the end of the day
is is it worth your upgrade is it worth
your money to upgrade from the Galaxy s3
or from other phones and right now the
verdict is if you have to have 1080p
AMOLED then yes this is the way to go
this is the only way to go if not then
you might be better off waiting the
software features you see here are
basically around the corner and a
firmware update from the galaxy s3 and
the Galaxy Note 2 and other Samsung
phones but what about other phones like
the HTC One or other 1080p devices well
there are some benefits to the galaxy s4
for example it's made of plastic which
is a pro because that gives you a
generally better signal strength you get
a lighter phone a little bit thinner and
you also get very fast GPS lock with a
plastic back but then again there are
cons like it being a fingerprint magnet
and feeling cheap in the hand so overall
that decision comes down to what you
prefer in a phone overall though I think
this is a great phone I'm definitely
enjoying every second I spend with it
and maybe you will too this is
definitely worth checking out I think I
would go with the black version over the
white version though just for the clean
look and less fingerprints either way
thank you for watching definitely
subscribe and stay tuned for upcoming
videos that relate to this one very very
very very soon and you're definitely
going to want to see those so I'll talk
to you guys in the next video
ace
you